We return to our IPython Notebook to answer the question if we
will have enough data for the chosen features.
In this block of code, we draw some histograms.
We have already seen what histograms represent.
Let's first run the code, and then we will analyze the plots.
Once it finishes running, you will see a histogram that looks like this.
In this histogram,
we're plotting the inter-sampling time in minutes in the X axis.
The Y axis shows the frequency for each of these inter-sampling times.
The bins here are bins of 60 minutes.
You see the value between 0 and 60 has the maximum number of data points.
If you scroll down,
you will see the same histograms now drawn for each of the persons.
In this case, this is the histogram for person A, and
we see that most of person A's samples are also between 0 and 60 minutes.
You can keep scrolling down and examine the histograms for
each of these persons.
In this case, this is person B, person C, person D, and so on.
We ask the question, if we have enough data for
the inter-sampling time of 60 minutes?
The answer, in this case, is yes.
So we asked a question and
then validated it by showing that there's adequate frequency of data.
Then we come to the next question.
Is there enough data to distinguish pattern?
This is a very important question because we
want features with the most discriminating power.
What that means is that the features that we use should be
able to separate each individual in the best way possible.
We have already seen in lesson two how we
can select features that give us the most discriminating power.
Here, we are going to do a simple visual inspection of the data patterns and
not dive into any of the methods previously used to decorrelate features.
However, we must verify that the selected traces that we are using are distinct.